plenty of games coming up on sunday
there are only three of them left in the
regular season stats take us through the
list we're actually starting on saturday
mike houston at the jets
chris is this the start of a new winning
streak for the texans uh i i mean i do
expect it to be a new winning streak for
the texans i expect them to win this
football game i don't think it'll be
necessarily easy i'll say that much
you know i do think that houston's
defense is going to give the jets a hard
time moving the ball but i think the
other way around too
i think the jets defense and todd bowles
he's pretty good at breaking down
offenses houston can be a little simple
in the past game when their run game
doesn't work i think houston wins but
like kind of like a 24-13 type game
where it was 17-13 in the fourth and the
texans put them away late
this is gonna be a common theme for me
the last few weeks of the season as it
relates to teams that are not in the
playoff hunt where does their motivation
come from guys be making business
decisions during the game well guys who
otherwise could have played not played
because of injuries that they don't want
to make worse going into the off season
and when you have a coach in todd bowles
who is presumptively out the door does
the locker room rally do they check out
a lot of that stuff you just can't tell
until it's time to play the game that's
why i think the texans who have far more
to play for find a way to pull it
together and pull off the victory and if
they can't maybe they shouldn't be in
the playoff conversation
yeah i'm with you there i expect them to
do it too but i do think the jets will
give a spirited effort and give them a
tough time
baker and the browns are going to denver
mike what's more likely the broncos get
torched by baker mayfield or the denver
defense just shuts them down
i think it's more likely that they get
torched by baker mayfield there's
something special about mayfield and the
browns even though they're not
realistically in the playoff hunt
although there's a path that's not all
that crazy for them to potentially sneak
in this is about laying the foundation
for what we're gonna see next year and
we saw baker mayfield's debut in prime
time on a thursday night back in
september this is another chance to play
at night even though it's not a national
broadcast it's i mean like you know
three-letter network it's still nfl
network at night i think mayfield's
going to bring it the browns are going
to bring it and and i think that because
the broncos lost last week they realize
it's not going to happen for them this
year i think the browns uh and it's i'm
sure it's an upset but i i like the
browns and i like what mayfield's gonna
do chris yeah i certainly wouldn't be
surprised if they won i mean if you're
gonna make me pick i'm gonna go the
broncos in a close one because i do
think denver at home is a tough place to
play that crowd noise and once vod
miller and bradley chubb just get that
little advantage of jumping off the ball
there they are tough to beat but
i think that the browns and baker
mayfield like you will have some success
moving the ball i just think case keenum
and then will move the ball as well on
the cleveland defense but you know the
one thing we've seen that the broncos
have struggled with teams that can run
the ball and do effective play actions
off of that stats you saw the 49ers
expose the the broncos with that last
week yeah i did yeah you did i know you
like that nick chubb is phenomenal and
freddy kitchens has done a great job
staying patient with the run and
designing great play action passes off
of it for baker mayfield and we know he
can sling that ball all over the field
broncos win a close one in my eyes like
23 20 because they're home
the packers of green bay go to chicago
chris are we gonna see aaron rodgers
light up that bear's d like we did in
week one or the bears gonna shut him
down like they did against the rams last
week yeah there's always the aaron
rodgers effect that scares me but i i
would i would err more on bears shutting
down the packers i didn't see anything
new from that packers offense last week
it's still the same old crappy scheme
and it's all about aaron rodgers
scrambling or aaron rodgers throwing
unbelievable one-on-one throws he was
leading his team and rushing for the
better part of the game until the game
finally got in hand and they broke a few
runs late in the fourth quarter with
aaron jones
this bears defense is special they're at
home they realize the packers have
gotten the best of them over the last
two years i think the bears win like a
27-17 game stats
and look here's the thing
the packers really do have a chance to
get to the postseason that that the help
they need isn't all that complicated the
hardest part is for a team that has been
oh and six on the road all year to go to
chicago and win if they could somehow
pull this off they really have a
plausible shot of the postseason and i'm
kind of rooting for it not just because
the packers were my preseason super bowl
pick and i hey i want them to be as
alive as long as possible i kind of like
the idea of the packers conducting head
coaching interviews the same week
they're getting ready for a playoff game
with their interim head coach there's
just something that is just fabulously
chaotic and awkward about that but yeah
i think the bears know dan i say this
all the time you don't want a team from
your own division in the playoffs yeah
this is a chance for the bears to
deliver a knockout blow to the packers
and and they still haven't won the
division yet and they still haven't
locked in as the three seats so they
have something to play for but if you
can get the packers out of the mix you
don't have to worry about them showing
up at soldier field in the playoffs like
they did back in 2010 with a super bowl
berth on the line get rid of him now so
you don't have to worry about them later
yeah that's right i agree with you there
the cowboys are going to indy to take on
the colts mike which dak shows up the
guy that was awesome in the fourth
quarter in overtime or the guy that
really stunk for the first three
quarters last week
well i i i don't know but here's the
reality as the cowboys win more games
that must win vibe necessarily goes away
and they're at a point now you know
they're kind of settled in as the 4c
they're gonna win the division they're
playing a colts team that is far more
desperate and chris you look at the five
wins the cowboys have strung together
not a single one was dominant i mean
they they had dominant physicality right
the score wasn't they were all close
games they all could have gone either
way and in this spot as you start to
maybe ease off the gas a little bit as
you collect yourself for the postseason
i could see the colts finding a way to
win this regardless of how dak prescott
plays i think the colts have the talent
they've got the offensive line they've
got the quarterback play they've got the
home field advantage and they've got the
incentive and i i throw it all together
and i say this is where the cowboys
winning streak ends okay all right you
like the colts that's a good one i i
mean it's a tough game here first of all
i'm going to era and we're going to see
the good dak prescott because even the
prescott you're talking about that stunk
in three quarters last week uh stats and
i understand why you're saying that
because he threw two big interceptions
that really you know made the game close
and it shouldn't be i was very
encouraged by what i saw other than
those two plays right i mean he really
has thrown the ball pretty well he's
made a lot of good decisions and we know
he's he's hitting mari cooper on a lot
of big plays a lot of the things mike
said scare me for dallas i mean yes i
expect the colts to be able to protect a
little bit against this dallas great
front four but do the colts have enough
weapons other than t y hilton in this
matchup to consistently move the ball
that was the thing i would question
because man this dallas defense is the
real deal they do play a lot of close
games which is scary like you said mike
but that's just the style of play
i'm taking the cowboys in a close one i
just think they're a little too talented
across the board for the colts right now
dangerous always with andrew luck at
home but i can't remember my i'm taking
cowboys 24-21 in this one
miami fresh off that emotional win chris
goes to minnesota to take on the vikings
are the dolphins due for a letdown yeah
i mean
they're still fighting for something so
i don't expect it to be a letdown i
think it's going to be tough sledding
though for them up there in minnesota
with that defense uh
i don't expect them to have a whole lot
of success on that side of the football
now really the big question of this
matchup is what do we expect from the
minnesota offense versus the dolphins
defense because i don't know what kind
of scheme you know minnesota's gonna run
what's the new offense going to look
like i think this game kind of stays
close for a little while because
minnesota's offense i'm not gonna you
know i gotta see it to believe it to say
they can just blow a team out like that
but i'm still gonna pick minnesota at
home because it's a tough place to play
and that defense is the real deal i'm
gonna go like a close 23 to 14 type
victory for the vikings at home
you know one of the realities of having
a win like the dolphins had last week
you have to reset quickly the vikings
went through that last year after they
beat the saints in the playoffs and
after getting blown out by the eagles
mike zimmer the coach of the vikings
acknowledged maybe we didn't put it
behind us as quickly as we needed to to
get focused on what was next and that
could be an issue for the dolphins but
for the vikings offenses in disarray
kevin stefanski takes over as the
coordinator he's been with the team
since 2006 so he's seen some good he's
seen a lot of bad and now we see what
kind of a play caller he's going to be
and that's the key and this guy i assume
is going to do what mike zimmer wants
him to do and that was john d filippo's
fatal flaw he wasn't listening to his
boss and his boss had to call him out
publicly to finally get what he wanted
he never got what he wanted so he has a
new coordinator so that's going to be i
think a real challenge can kevin
stevansky do what zimmer wants and will
it work we don't know that it'll work
because i haven't done it yet that's
right yeah we don't i mean yeah he he
learned a little under norv turner and
of course uh pat shurmur so you would
think he'd have some of those old-school
run plays that mike zimmer likes next
one go ahead stats keep rock uh railing
them off here titans at giants mike
considering what we saw from these
running backs last week is anybody going
to throw a pass in this game
i think the bigger question here can the
titans put together the kind of
consistency they haven't shown us all
year they've won two games in a row
they've had extra time to get ready for
this one and they are walking in to the
proverbial hornets nest in new york
because the giants they haven't gotten
the memo that it's in their best
interest to lose they are not giving up
i respect what they're doing and they
still have a very long shot but they're
not dead yet for a playoff birth this is
about the kind of consistency that the
titans are going to need to show if they
have any chance of making it to the
playoffs and you know what hurt them
last week is other six and six teams in
the afc one and it's going to be very
hard for them to get in but i think they
got to lay the foundation for next year
by showing that they can get a winning
streak together and find a way to be the
better version of the titans more often
than not yeah they're they're one of the
hardest teams to figure out in the nfl
this year for me i mean you just don't
know what to expect their defense has
great games and they get blown out you
know their offense has moments of going
whoa look at the explosive nature of
these players and mariota's on fire and
then they have games where they're less
than and you go they can't complete a
pass they can't do anything um i i don't
know what the status is of odell beckham
jr it sounds like he's not gonna be a
hundred percent even if he does play uh
and that scene he he had a quote
yesterday about his injury that we
cannot use he said that
thank you thank you for being very
subtle and nuanced in your you know
description of what went down thank you
you know me i'm subtle with those words
uh all right yeah but i'm gonna pick the
titans to win a close one that's what
i'm gonna say just because they are
still playing for something their
defense usually doesn't let up too many
touchdowns so i'm going titans 23-21
sorry picking against phil's team you're
gonna have some explaining to do
lamar jackson will get his first start
with joe flacco healthy and active so
lamar jackson the starting quarterback
moving forward for the baltimore ravens
chris sims they host the tampa bay
buccaneers the bucks are essentially
done they have a potentially potent
offense but i don't think the bucks have
seen a defense like the ravens right
do you think that the ravens are doing
the right thing by entrusting the
offense to lamar jackson with joe flacco
healthy yeah completely i do this is the
style i'll play their team's built on i
mean they're not you know the greatest
show on turf and i didn't ever turn down
the ravens to go oh let me watch joe
flacco and company throw for 400 yards
all over the field no this place is the
strength of their offense which is their
o-line it's big it's overpowering they
want to control the clock play their
defense off that right mike they just
want to beat you up physically i think
that's where it makes more sense for
lamar jackson yeah i think the joe
flacco era is definitely over and uh i'm
with you i i expect the
bucks to make a few plays in the past
game because they're dangerous but have
a hard time seeing them consistently
moving the ball on baltimore in
baltimore which is a tough place to play
so i like the ravens in this one and the
ravens were lifted by their their near
miss against the chiefs they come out of
it with confidence they think they can
leapfrog the steelers to win the afc
north so they're at home i don't see a
lapse and lamar jackson brings an
excitement my big concern with lamar
jackson though can he stay healthy right
and i say that about all quarterbacks
who play with physicality carson wentz
anybody who's running the ball can you
keep yourself healthy can you avoid
taking those hits that's the challenge
for lamar jackson or it will be back to
joe flacco before the season ends
seattle and san francisco getting
together the seahawks have owned that
series for years now and the seahawks i
you know the folks in vegas i think
they're trying to set somebody up i know
something that people don't because it's
a very
small margin i mean i see the seahawks
doing more of what they did when they
blew out the 49ers 43 to 16 earlier this
year yeah i i mean i hear you i'll say
this if
if you went back and watched the game
you'd go oh wait it's a little closer
than i remember for some reason the
49ers really messed up some situations
stats maybe he can remember but you had
wilson who fumbled inside the 10-yard
line when they were going in the score
they threw the 98-yard pick six
interception where they were going into
score there was a fumbled punt at one
time as well so there was
the the 49ers moved the ball on the
seahawks is basically what i'm saying
and i think that's why you're seeing
probably a close point spread i think
the the seahawks win this game
ultimately because they are playing for
something and they have russell wilson
and the 49ers usually find ways to mess
up a game somehow some way but i do
think this will be dangerous and it'll
be close like i think the seahawks win
this one like 24-20 mike something like
that
well i don't know i feel like the ceo
continue to get i i they get better and
better and better and i think they like
to prove points they like to settle
scores they can stick it to richard
sherman there's some chatter this week
by frank clark the seahawks defensive
lineman regarding sherman calling the
seahawks and middle of the road team i
just think the seahawks have have
slipped into a very special and rare
vibe where they're going to take on all
comers they're going to do everything
they can to kick your butts they don't
care that they're not going to be any
better than the 5 seed they are
motivated to win and win that's what
fascinates me about next week's game
against the chiefs they're going to be
motivated to beat everybody who they
encounter all right patriots and
steelers rematch of week 15 last year in
pittsburgh same week same spot same
kickoff time and do we feel anything
differently about the steelers ability
to handle situational football after the
way they bungled that selection of plays
that they made when they had a chance to
win the game last year after the
reversal of the jesse james touchdown no
i don't feel any better about their
ability to handle situational football
we saw them bungle the denver broncos
game a few weeks ago with the rpo and
the one-yard line they too
have dominated football teams the last
few weeks and found teams found ways to
lose the game
i think they match up very well with the
new england patriots the new england
patriots is not the old we want to
spread the field out and you know dink
and dunk and let brady be surgical and
pick apart your zone defense the
steelers uh their defense is better than
years past they're a little more diverse
in their coverages mike and their
disguises and they can play a little
man-to-man when they need to but new
england wants to run the ball with two
backs in the backfield and play that
type of game i think that's going to be
tough to do against pittsburgh and i do
think pittsburgh is going to be able to
move the ball on new england i'm picking
new england i mean not not new england
sorry pittsburgh and a close one oddly
enough i just think they're desperate
they're gonna they're sick of hearing
about the patriots and i think of all
years this is their best chance i think
they really match up well i'm gonna say
like 27 24 steelers that sounds crazy
but i'm doing it well you look i would
have agreed with you but for the fact
that the patriots are coming into this
one after that right now right right
real quickly sunday night football
eagles rams you have any faith in nick
foles whatsoever to upset an la team
that is desperate to win absolutely not
absolutely not i don't care if it was
wednesday
or superman they're in deep crap okay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports